[Music]
princess charlotte is really coming into
her personality the seven-year-old royal
attended the commonwealth games with the
duke and duchess of cambridge and she
shines in the spotlight while the royal
family was watching a hockey match
between england and india in birmingham
charlotte yeah she had a quite a few
questions for her parents
that's when the funny faces began
exhibit a charlotte with her mouth wide
open as prince william tries to explain
what's going on
exhibit b duchess kate steps in to give
her take and poor charlotte looks pretty
confused and exhibit c girl looks
completely over it
[Laughter]
whether the adorable royal understands
the commonwealth games or not charlotte
looked the part in a cute nautical
striped dress and braided hairstyle this
marked charlotte's first time stepping
out with her parents without her
siblings prince george and prince louis
and the cambridges know a thing or two
about cheering on a team
we both want to wish the lionesses the
best of luck for tonight
just days before charlotte and her dad
made a surprise appearance in a video
posted by the palace supporting the
lionesses women's soccer team
you've done amazingly well in the
competition and we're rooting for you
all the way
good luck i hope you win bye
we think charlotte looks like a spitting
image of prince william and judging by
her etiquette she's shaping up to be a
fine royal too
[Music]
no surprise here because the young lady
corrected her older brother george's
posture last month in june during the
queen's platinum jubilee
but it didn't stop there charlotte kept
her brothers in check all week
yup when four-year-old prince louis
started waving during the carriage ride
princess charlotte quickly put a pause
on that earlier charlotte took charge to
stop louis from waving in their
horse-drawn carriage along with prince
george their mum the duchess of
cambridge and camilla the duchess of
cornwall next to their great-grandmother
and on the balcony charlotte wasn't
having it when louis made funny faces
the four-year-old had the best facial
expressions as he waved wildly to the
crowd and chatted to his
great-grandmother the queen his antics
had his sister charlotte actually
scolding him at one point telling him to
pay attention
well after seeing charlotte's funny
faces at the commonwealth games seems
it's ironically come full circle
[Music]
you